it's unfortunate that people have um
taken such sides here because this is
something that has been going on for
decades Sunny host here she is racist
leftist
wokester possibly the most unlikable
dishonest person on television Sunny
host uh here she runs cover for Hamas
the exact way that these last two things
that we showed you have done it's
unfortunate that people have um taken
such side here because this is something
that has been going on for decades right
and um we did show the reunification of
of Jewish families and I think that was
really important especially little AB
Abigail I'm a mother um I can't imagine
having your your your child taken from
you and held hostage by a terrorist
organization but we also there were you
know 76 Palestinians including women and
children that were being held in Israel
with no no understanding of why they
were being held no Administrative
Hearings and so those um those
reunifications are something that we
should also be looking at and talking
she's evil like she is just evil I can't
say what I want to call her but you know
what I want to call her she is just evil
the the trying to make the moral
equivalence between these people she's
also lying that there was no trials for
these people there are trials for these
people they there is videotape of people
stabbing people and the Litany of things
we all know that and that she opens it
up by saying it's unfortunate we have to
take Sid you amoral
vapid here's another clip of Sunny
hustin um I think that you're absolutely
right whoopy what is media allowed in
Gaza yes there is media in Gaza I've
seen these videos I try to watch the BBC
I try to watch Al jazer I try to get my
news I try to get my news everywhere
because I and I think every one should
um and I I I think what's really
important is what happens after this
pause because the ceas fire apparently
is a bad word now so what happens after
this humanitarian pause who is in charge
who isn't in charge are we going to
continue seeing this Devastation in in
in Gaza are we going to continue seeing
these three Palestinian kids going
college kids one who knows my son's
friend okay uh when is that going to
stop when are we going to really meet at
the table and understand that all lives
in this situation are being affected and
we must have a two-state solution no you
dimwit um for oh my God somebody knows
her son somebody was some her son has a
friend I'm sorry for her son for his
mother um you cannot have a two-state
solution in the aftermath of what just
happened and I already explained partly
why geographically it makes no sense the
the cause of the entire Palestinian
movement is only to kill Jews they have
been offered State six times there has
been no Jew in Gaza since 2006 the
Israelis want nothing to do with the
place she's she's she's dumb she's it's
dumb and she's evil and I don't know
what to do with these people I really do
not know what you do with these people
uh and what they are doing is they are
causing anguish and despair decent
people